la tercera ola del cobi 19 golpea duro
en américa argentina por ejemplo esta
semana alcanzó récords de contagios que
no había visto en toda la pandemia y por
eso el gobierno de alberto fernández
ordenó cerrar las escuelas durante dos
semanas la polémica se encendió primero
el alcalde de la ciudad de buenos aires
horacio rodríguez recurso la decisión
ante la corte suprema y luego miles de
argentinos salieron a las calles el
sábado se quedan sin educación los unen
en la ignorancia y van a crear
generaciones de chicos pauperizados en
su moral y en su intelectualidad por eso
marchamos el cansancio del encierro
también se siente en canadá en la
provincia de ontario donde está toronto
las autoridades locales decretaron por
tercera vez un aislamiento total para
muchos canadienses la culpa es del
gobierno por no haber tomado las medidas
necesarias a tiempo
en respuesta salieron a las calles
masivamente el sábado
el bloqueo no funciona mentalmente no
funciona para la salud mental de muchos
las protestas contra el confinamiento se
extienden por otros países de américa
como en colombia donde muchos
comerciantes rechazan los aislamientos
durante los fines de semana que se están
aplicando en varias ciudades del país
la enfermedad muy terrible eso no lo
negamos yo la viví el año pasado estuve
15 días en cama a causa el coronavirus
pero le digo que es más fuerte que esta
enfermedad la crisis económica porque
con hambre no se vive aunque muchos
insisten en que no pueden más con el
aislamiento las autoridades reiteran que
esta es una de las medidas que tienen
para contrarrestar la pandemia hasta que
la vacunación sea masiva